at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands this episode
is brought to you by me undies if I'm
not going commando I'm in me Andes I
have been testing these underwear for
three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout a bunch
of my other underwear this morning and
on the road in the house they are
extremely comfortable they look good
feel good they are made of micro mode al
two times softer than cotton as
scientifically tested using the cob
bottom method sounds very fancy of
course and I get a lot of compliments
from ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies comm forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing their ridiculous the sublime
everything in between including my
favorite which is called out and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention their
lounge pants this is a new thing and
I've been wearing their lounge pants
when I record podcasts I've been wearing
them out and about when I'm walking the
dog meeting people for coffee and they
are extremely comfortable they're made
from the same material as the underwear
but some of them like the blue ones I
have have pockets so you can walk about
without seeming like you're off of your
meds and completely crazy so that is
awesome
and if you're not happy with the first
pair you try on I assume that refers to
the underwear they'll refund you
completely and you can keep the pair you
tried on for free but if you're that
kind of person you should be ashamed
because that's disgusting
me Andy's com4 slash Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years I love
audiobooks and I have to to recommend
right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing you will thank me
to the graveyard book the second is
vagabonding by ralph pots which had a
huge impact on my life and formed the
basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible.com forward slash tim TI m and
you can choose one of those two books or
you can choose from more great options
than you can possibly imagine so that
could be a book that could be a magazine
that could be a newspaper it could be a
class it's that easy go to audible.com
forward slash Tim that's audible.com
forward slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
hello boys and girls kittens and
squirrels this is Tim Paris and welcome
to another episode of the Tim Ferriss
show where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers the best of the
best in many different worlds whether
that be chess military or in this case
entertainment now I have wanted to get
Shep Gordon on this show for probably a
year and a half two years and it'll be
very clearer than the first few minutes
of this conversation why he has been
named one of the 100 most influential
people by Rolling Stone magazine and he
is the man he is the icon behind the
icons behind some of the biggest names
you've ever heard you can say hello to
him on twitter and instagram at supermen
Shep if you like these storytelling and
lessons of Calvin you're going to love
this episode Shep has worked with and
befriended and has some incredible
stories about hilarious stories which
you're going to hear some of the biggest
names in the entertainment industry from
Alice Cooper to Bette Davis Raquel Welch
to Groucho Marx blondie to Jimi Hendrix
Sylvester Stallone to Salvador Dali
Luther Vandross to Teddy Pendergrass and
his job was in effect he had many jobs
but to make them as famous as possible
and we we dig into how he did that the
PR stunts the biggest successes the
biggest failures there were quite a few
that blew up right in his face
on top of that he is credited with
inventing the celebrity chef phenomenon
which revolutionized the food industry
and turned the culinary arts into the
multi-billion dollar industry that it is
today he worked with all of the first
wave of the now known as celebrity chefs
Nobu Matsuhisa Emeril Lagasse Wolfgang
Puck Roger Vijay and many others and
then on top of that he's done quite a
bit with His Holiness the Dalai Lama and
it doesn't end there
now Anthony Bourdain a huge fan of
Shep's has released a memoir detailing
Shep's life and adventures titled they
call me super mensch a backstage pass to
the amazing world of film food and
rock-and-roll and I've been reading this
and enjoying every page because it is
hard to conceive of how many stories and
life lessons Shep has it is like the
titta lysing totalizing is that a real
word
the raucous drug-infused party story
combined with the best MBA you could
possibly receive so without further ado
please enjoy my conversation with chef
Gordon Shep welcome to the show I am so
happy it's my pleasure and I was
mentioning before we started recording
that about a year ago I took my family
on a trip for Christmas and we all sat
down and we watched supermen CH and the
collective thought was at some point in
time that you need to connect with this
ship character so I'm very excited to
have you on the line and could you place
for the people listening where you are
at the moment
yeah when on a beautiful white sand
beach folky Alva Kapoor Beach on the
Southwest Shore of Maui you might be
able to hear some waves rolling in the
background and I'm sitting on my porch
which overlooks the ocean and feeling
very very lucky and how did you end up
in Hawaii because I know it's it's a
very important place to you and not only
that but your home has been a a refuge
of sorts for many many people including
notable folks for decades now but how
did you end up in Hawaii like many
things in my life what partly by
accident partly by taking action I
wanted to quit smoking this is back in
the early 70s and I had read about a
house that Colonel Tom Parker who was
Elvis Presley's manager had rented and
howell lulu and draw his office over to
a big spread and Colonel Parker was a
hero I said oh my god if I could sleep
in Colonel Parker's bed and quit smoking
what a cool thing to do I rented the
house it was in Kahala in Hollywood and
brought a bunch of people from my office
over sadly we weren't environmentally
conscious in 72 and I remember we all
threw our cigarettes out the window
driving in from the airport
and I just got in with the wrong crowd
and how it wasn't working at all my
spiral was sort of going deeper and I
decided I had to leave my Lulu go to an
outer Island I had a friend who had a
tour going to the outer island and those
days I had a hydrofoil I took the
hydrofoil
put one foot on the dock in Maui and
turned around at my friend and said I'm
living here the rest of my life
and I just feel different in my skin
here it's been very magical now if we
were to look at rewinding the clock and
a shift in location how did you get your
start in the music business for people
who do not know the backstory
another great accident and I have great
accidents I was always a child in the
sixties and liberal Jewish social
socialist leaning activist very active
against the war or active against ROTC
and always had a vision of myself as a
young man it's like a saviour on a white
horse charging into trouble and so I
took a job as a probation officer I
hadn't long hair I was using
psychedelics and I thought what a
beautiful thing to bring love and peace
to probation whole young kids it was a
Reagan error I thought they were being
you know misused misguided and went to
California got a job as a probation
officer didn't work sort of got beat up
by the kids the first day I realized I
was not gonna change the system by being
a probation officer and drove into
Hollywood late at night didn't have a
lot of money there was a small motel
that had a vacancy sign checked into the
hotel and a balcony it was a it was
exactly Hotel California there was two
stories around the swimming pool palm
trees a life I didn't know and you know
went out on the porch and took a little
psychedelics you felt a little sorry for
myself having just been beat up in a
jail but also felt amazingly empowered
to be on my own in California free
healthy
and I heard someone screaming down at
the pool a girl and having just come
from a jail my brain for some reason
went to violence and I thought she was
being raped and I ran down a wall and
separated these two people and the girl
got very mad punched me in the mouth
they were making love I took the wrong
guess and in the morning when I went
down to the pool the girl was Janis
Joplin and around the pool was sort of
the Hollywood Wax Museum Jimi Hendrix
I'm Jim Morrison would come and go the
Chambers Brothers who were very big in
those days and I was big fans of and my
journey began one day
Lester chambers said to me what else you
do for a living Clay's thought its
selling some psychedelics to everybody
at the hotel and I said I don't really
know and he said are you Jewish I said
yes he said you should be a manager
yes and he introduced me to Alice Cooper
and I've managed him for 47 years so I
have I I'm replaying the documentary in
my mind and it seems like as you
mentioned you've had some fantastic
accidents but you've also created some
incredible things in your life and you
seem to be a master PT Barnum of sorts
and I was hoping you could discuss some
of the some of your favorite stunts that
you've put together because the one that
Joe the one that jumps to mind and there
that I'd love to hear about a few of
them but but at least one that comes to
mind was the the broken-down truck in
London but you can tackle them in any
order that you'd like but I just think
these are so genius I'd love for you to
explain a few of them I start with
Piccadilly my philosophy was that you
didn't have to wait for history that you
could create history and
we were in the entertainment business so
different than maybe in politics where
you create history there aren't there
aren't really victims so I always felt
good about creating history in an
entertainment sense and the key to
really managing an artist was to try and
understand what what is it that appeals
to their audience
what is if you can get it down to a word
of two words or three words sex appeal a
rebellion of Peola there's this broad
categories that if you can tap into you
can pick up a big audience and with
Alice we realized very early on it was
hatred of parent that every child at
some point in their life rebelled
against their parents I lived through it
now my kids came home with hip hop music
and it's like what are you doing and I
knew that pop music would be gigantic
because that's that's the way life works
it works that way enclosed and works
that way and everything so I knew my
focus my focus was getting parents over
the breakfast table to tell their
children if you dare buy an Alice Cooper
record or go see him you're grounded if
I could accomplish that so I never
really cared about the music magazines I
cared about Newsweek time the network
TVs I cared about the things the parents
watch not the kids mmm
because I didn't really know how to get
the kids except for paint this is the
payola period it was paying for hit
records and we didn't have money so we
start making some progress in America it
starts working we start pulling stunts
off Alice we get very lucky with the
tricking incident where I threw a
chicken on stage and the press thought
that Alice bit his head off and said
this hot these horrible stories about
him which broke him wide open in America
and I assumed it's great thing when they
get to England there's no ticket sales
and I'm now trying to figure out how do
I in a matter of 10 days get every
parent in London to hate Alice Cooper
that's not an easy task and so I go in
there was a brilliant guy working in
Waterboro
who was the fifth Beatle Derek Taylor he
was there PR man and he was brilliant
and he said tell me about this Alice
Cooper he had never heard of Alice
Cooper and I told him and I told him
what I was thinking we started talking
and I said is there anything that all
the parents and London watch or do or
see and he said well the morning shows
or gigantic because everybody checks
into the traffic before they leave home
there's helicopters and it's it's really
big it's like our TV and Britain is very
boring but this is something that gets a
lot of views hmm and what's the what's a
bit of busiest traffic in the morning at
rush hour at Piccadilly square it's
always backed up and out of that develop
this that we had just done a photo shoot
with Avedon which was Alice naked with a
snake covering his genitals so I said to
Derek you know we just had this great
shot and I took it out and said what do
you think about putting it on like a
flatbed truck and breaking it down at
Piccadilly would that piss everybody off
that he's that come on they said we
could do this and he said you know we
can and he found a driver and he paid
for the truck through Warner Brothers
and we asked the guy to break it down
two or three times until they arrested
him because we knew they would arrest
them but that was our story and it hit
the morning news it was helicopters
traffic was backed-up 30 miles we had
yesterday this is 72 or 73 we had girls
on the flatbed truck in hot pants giving
out flyers it sold out there's also many
things that didn't work because when you
live on the edge like that there's so
many things that don't work and and I
think I just I just gave a talk to a
bunch of DJ's and business guys in that
world and what I tried to get across is
that the failures were almost more
important than the successes that's
really what separated Alice and I from
so many other managers and artists and
what made his career go so long it's
because we were both allowed to fail and
we supported each other so here's a
great failure story he gets his first
stadium show Three Rivers Stadium
and I'm trying to think what do I do
it's a baseball stadium we have to do
something really Alice Cooper us cuz
everything's gonna be so small on a tiny
stage even in those days they I don't
even think they were using screens in
concerts this was really early days and
was I think the first stadium show maybe
other than the Beatles at Shea Stadium
there were very few stadiums
so I said I got it she's of course the
stadium out of a cannon
how cool would that thing Alice Cooper
going through the state of it so I go to
Warner Brothers who built all our props
they did the guillotine and they did
that the gallows and the guy there was
so nonchalant about it he said to me
after explain to what I wanted he said
what period cannon hey you gotta be
kidding me he said no World War 1 World
War two Revolutionary War and I said
give me your best can and he went to a
drawer and he took out blueprints for a
cannon with someone in it to get shot of
course he didn't have it's a stadium but
it was it was the trick it was a shallow
bottom the trick was Alice would crawl
in the cannon go into a bottom that was
pitiless it was a dummy already dressed
like him looking like him he would run
he would crawl out of the cannon run
around get driven around to the other
side of the stadium we would do some
stick you know with flames getting ready
to blow up the cannon when he got there
bingo and it would go across the stadium
and Alice would come out triumphant well
we did it the first night for rehearsal
in the cannon which was 40 feet long and
six tons the dummy came out who when
maybe one foot just flopped out yeah
just flopped it was the worst thing I
ever saw but Alice couldn't see he was
at the cabin how was it I said the worst
thing I've ever seen in my life
and I made a very rookie mistake which I
never made again which was advertising
what we were gonna do no no watch Alice
get shot as we can and we sold out
and we had press coming in the night
before to send stories back to the news
because that's all you had was like the
6 o'clock news and they wouldn't have
been oh I got it so now what are we
gonna do now I could go to sleep I'll
figure it out he wakes up in the hotel
were fire extinguishes it had foam so
what are we gonna do I said it's going
to be a giant penis
these tube falls on it I totally get up
with this foam you get on it and rub it
you lick it and just masturbated to
death and the foam will come out 40 50
yards you know Rose it'll be fantastic
and I'll figure out what I tell
Pittsburgh so he gets in any drug that
he worked so hard and it drips out it's
worse than the night before and now this
is a time when most managers and artists
would be choking each other to death
that is the point I want to make out of
this story now why is that don't whine
I've now it back I'm a manager I thought
of it I put him on a stage and the most
embarrassing sitting on it right as a
normal human being
not to mention even an artist you would
tend to give the guy grief who put you
in this horrible situation it's horrible
and I it was all on me a hundred percent
on me
I write the shows with Alice he lets me
do everything it's a hundred percent on
my shoulders instead of it he said can
you cover it and I said yeah he went to
sleep and I stayed up all night and I
figured out okay how do I turn this
disaster into a gigantic win for Alice
Cooper what would be even bigger for
Alice Cooper's we sold out so that's
okay even bigger for him than getting
shot out of the cannon and here's what
we did
he showed up the next night the cannon
blew up he was in the cannon when it
blew up the TV crews were there they
watch from getting taken off into the
ambulance we announced from the hospital
that he it wasn't serious and that he
was going to come and do the show and we
did the show with him in a wheelchair
and nurses and doctors everybody giving
him plasma nothing happened to him it
was all a setup page paper was about how
great Alice Cooper was what other
artists in the world would come and show
his audience
oh so you you know out of that failure
came even a stronger bond and I think
you know that's one of the important
lessons to learn from that is that if
you're it takes a family to make a
business as much as a family as a as it
takes to make a family you know it takes
a group of town a village and other
people you work with you need to allow
them to fail well they'll never really
win cuz they both the tide so closely
together in the creative world now you
so I want to underscore a few things and
ask a follow-up question the first is
you talked about aiming to upset the
parents in say London or the UK so in a
way you're doing almost the opposite of
for instance the founding editor of
Wired magazine talks about 1,000 true
fans and trying to find your 1,000 true
fans but you did it indirectly almost by
trying to find targeting your 1,000 true
haters I mean finding the people who
would do your advertising for you by
disliking you which i think is just so
interesting there's very specific reason
I think that art is a very narrow window
when it comes to personal choice the
largest entertainment figures of our
decade all had one thing in common
hatred of parents on the Beatles were
horrible the Rolling Stones pissed on
gas stations Bob Dylan fun feet she has
guys with dopers it's there's only a few
things that every single person goes
through they go through rebellion if
they don't go through it they end up on
a rooftop killing people so my attempt
was to pick up rather than get a
thousand people who loved Alice for what
Alice did if I could make him the face
of a rebellion I had a huge audience to
pick from and in 72 it was the biggest
tour of the world and before we started
recording we were chatting a little bit
about and we didn't get into it because
I I've speaking of rookie mistakes I've
learned that it's best to talk about it
when you've hit record
but we have a mutual friend maybe others
but at least one mutual friend and Rick
Rubin and he's he said to me before you
know the best art divides the audience I
a hundred percent that's such a that is
such an educated statement and well I
think we'll definitely come back to -
Rick you mentioned the rookie mistake of
announcing what you're going to do
before you did it
are there any other particular rookie
mistakes that you made or that you see
managers making and this might be a good
time just for people who are outside of
the entertainment and music worlds to
define what a manager is exactly what
does the manager do I think it's a you
know it's it's not a curriculum
profession so I think it's a wide range
for me as a manager I always envisioned
my job was to get an artist so he didn't
have to use his second name that to me
was my focus to make him an internet you
know no one it says Alice who or Luther
who or Groucho who or right gal who who
are my clients there are other managers
who were very very dollar orientated you
can squeeze a blood out of a dollar
there's other managers who are great at
getting Coca Cola's meaning actually
fetching the beverages for the area it's
really an artist driven profession for
the most part it's what they're looking
for and what their need what they're
willing to share and it's a very wide
range I think there's for me the really
talented managers are the ones who get a
head of their client by six months or a
year and go come this way I notice a
pothole right here be careful we really
have a vision of what the audience is
what the attraction is how to put it in
a picture frame that doesn't compromise
it doesn't make the artist chase the
flavor of the month but knows how to
promote the essence of what they are
which gets so much the what Rick Rubin's
comment was that once you have the
success and you have your audience
you're never gonna keep him at a
rebellion because they're gonna drop off
in five or six years rebellion goes
bye-bye
so it's a matter of taking that and
taking the essence of what this artist
has creatively it makes them a great
artist and putting that in the picture
frame with the people who picked them up
by these broad strokes say yes that's
that I can relate to I want to stay with
that so I what he said it's so brilliant
I never really thought of it like that I
always say it's been the other side is
it you pick up your broadest audience by
social revelations rather than art but
that's obscure but what he's saying is
perfectly right so each one of those
artists depending on what they want to
do with their art is very different some
making the most money is the most
important some being the most famous is
the most important so I'm not being told
what to do this is the most important so
different than a doctor or an accountant
there's no real curriculum and no where
they really learn to be a manager I'm
gonna come back to the rookie mistakes
question but I have to bring up because
it was it was one of the most hilarious
portions of the doc with Mike Meyers
which was a flashback dramatization a
reenactment of getting one of your
clients to agree to have you as a
manager but there was a competition of
sorts and I was just thinking to myself
this is not the type of thing when you
said there's no curriculum this was
probably not the case study that would
be used in an MBA program about music
and entertainment management but d-iii
I'm guessing that you you remember which
example this is good could you please
replay this for folks in some ways not
my proudest moment I was impressed
nonetheless proud or proud or not and
it's something I never would have ever
talked about it's Teddy its it regards
an artist named Teddy Pendergrass and he
was a very macho after American artist I
would have never talked about this if he
hadn't actually written it in his book
which amazed me who has vivid thought
that it was early on in my career I was
very successful and had a great
reputation which didn't exist in the
management business at that time
and one of my clients was gradual marks
and the executor of gradual marks as a
state was a gentleman from CBS named
Goddard Lieberson and he was very good
to Groucho and he was a legend then my
armpits got sweaty every time I went to
see him you know he was a living legend
and he had someone in CBS to reach out
to me to ask me if I would manage go
look at meet with Teddy Pendergrass to
management he was a very important
artist to the label and they would like
me to be involved and you couldn't say
no that to Goddard so I went to
Philadelphia I didn't really like the
show but I realized that the fellow
named Teddy Pendergrass was actually the
lead singer of pound Milton and the blue
notes who wore one of my favorite groups
so I went backstage it was a long line
of Jewish managers they were all these
great characters Sid Sheinberg who and
all these companies his name
Sid Arthur I think was Arthur shot at
China and it was SAS and he had SAS code
mass go fast go fast go fast Leatherhead
was spent managed bvk universe but there
was all these great Jewish managers
backstage so I didn't even bother going
in I went home about a week later they
called me up how was the meeting didn't
take the meeting
please mr. Leverson would like you to
take it would you go back down and take
the meeting I go back down pull up to
his driveways a white Rolls Royce with
license plate Eddie I go up to the
penthouse it's beautiful girl in like a
lingerie opens the door then this the
most beautiful man I've ever seen in my
life comes walking in and I completely
dropped everything I was gonna say and I
decided this is a really this is not
gonna happen let me just get out of here
so I said what's the man wanted there's
not a lot of things I know in life but
there's one thing I know for sure you
have no credentials whatsoever
to figure out which one of us
fast-talking Jews is telling the truth
you had the best group in the bunch and
there's no way you're gonna know who's
telling the truth so here's what I
suggest let's get together for a weekend
bring the best drugs you have bring the
best women you have bring the best booze
you have and let's just party and if you
drop before I do on the wrong guy for
you
if I drop before you if you drop before
I do I should be a manager because when
you collapse I'll be able to take the
money from the huge out of your pocket
and save it and he looked at me like I
was completely out of my mind as he says
in his book but then he said yes and oh
[ __ ] now I got to do this and we met in
New York in a hotel and we did what we
said we were gonna do and he collapsed a
couple of days later and I managed them
the rest of his life without a contract
and by the way never collapsed again and
there were there were at least a few I
suppose innovations we could call them
that came of that collaboration I think
for me as a manager that may have been
the the crowning point of creating
history because it was so focused and it
was um I had an artist who was big
enough that I had the luxury I could do
it and I had an artist who completely
completely trusted me because all we hit
were headwinds but the concept was I was
trying to Teddy sex-appeal
was unbelievable the amount of panties
we would get on stage and bras with
phone numbers the reaction of even old
Jewish women but unbelievable the sex
was just unbelievably strong songs his
producer - they allowed us order to
really Drive it so we produced a stage
show that went to that we produced songs
and went to that closed the door songs
like that that really highlighted sex
not romance sex and then I was trying to
say how do I tell this to the public how
do I really get across that this is a
black Elvis how do I get I have every
black person in America how do I get the
white audience to see it and really get
it and understand that and I came up
with this concept out of a very angry
moment you add one of his first shows
where I had to wait backstage while the
bevy of women went into his dressing
room and I was really angry and I said
to them after I got to see him I said
yeah this is crazy man we should do
shows for women only that's it so that I
have a chance
but BV in the in the house with the
women and added we both looked at each
other he said can you do that and he
said I can do it and everybody fought me
they lawyers from the halls called me up
it's you know it's bigotry I said no no
we'll sell tickets to women we're just
gonna say for women only and that's what
we did we devised an ad we did concerts
across America Radio City Music Hall on
New York Greek Theater LA we did
concerts for women only we had a hundred
percent women I don't think one man
showed up at any of them we gave that
chocolate teddy bear lollipops which was
so hot and then we got to it well we're
going to advertise that I got to her
challenge point which was there is a
line between saying what you are and
being arrogant about what you are and
when I saw the ad with this picture on
it I said the women only coming out of
teddy is a little arrogant so we act we
ended up not using his picture we got a
stuffed little teddy bear that every
girl loves and we put an old load on it
to said come spend the night with me
love teddy really soften it up and it
sold out in like a second and they were
fantastic shows and then I I said I was
managing Luther Vandross and I said okay
how do I apply that same set of
principles to Luther who's not sex
Luther was romance Luther was all about
wining and dining and the anticipation
how beautiful romanticism so what I did
with him which I thought was not as
focused as Teddy but the same highway
which was we gave out to the top radio
stations in America a contest where you
could win Luther marrying you on the air
so it really drove romance and I think
weddings if you look at statistics with
his music for that decade was probably
the most played wedding songs so anyway
that's that's and I tell you have fun
and I tell you develop an artist but all
those things to get back to failure take
an artist and a manager trusting each
other to go out on a limb the question
of failure a question of mistakes made
are there any other
rookie mistakes that you see a lot of
people making in the position of
something like a manager or that you
made that come to mind
any particular sort of archetypal or
critical mistakes yeah I think it's less
a list of mistakes and it's it's a
mistake of intentions what I see at
least from the people I see and talk to
is they're not in the business really
for service they're in the business for
greed and out of greed you just these
stupid things and your visions blurred
if you're in it for service to your
artist which is really a manager I mean
again if there are different types of
managers there are managers who are
power guys who I get it they build
empires often and they're great for
their artists but I think you know I
have an assistant who has a daughter
who's being sought after by everybody in
the music business record company's
managers publishers she's a beautiful 21
year old girl Lily meola
and I see the difference between the
phone calls that come in for her and the
things that I do for Alice like I wake
up for Alice and I think about how am I
going to enhance his career how am I
going to you know that was right now
we're running Alice for president we
wrote into the show at peace where
Hillary beats up Donald Trump in the
show and we have a Alice Cooper for
president with selling t-shirts we're
going viral and it's fun it's funny for
us but it's me waking up and thinking
what can I do to add to Alice's career
and most of these young people I see
coming around it when I sit and talk to
them they ask for advice
they're not asking you the device for
their artist they're asking advice for
them how do I get more clients how do I
put how can I get a piece of publishing
how can i I think it's a general rule
maybe for Humanity as as our
civilization moves along but I think
it's motivation more than actual things
wrong because I think again there's no
school for management so every managers
gonna make lots of mistakes it reminds
me of a story I've heard you tell I
think it was in a commencement speech
actually I might be miss placing that
but you were talking about a guide to
cooking
from I want to say some type of holiness
Dalai Lama exactly and 90% of it or more
was about the intention of when you
select the rice and when you boil the
rice and and only perhaps 10% of it was
was technical let me ask you how do you
maintain that orientation or how did you
come to have that service orientation
because of course I would imagine all
things equal you want to be financially
successful as a manager so that you can
do the things you want to do and so on
and I guess it's a byproduct of making
your clients financially successful but
how did you maintain that lens of
service over greed did it ever get the
best of you and then you correct course
hurt or did that and has that not been
the case you know it's a it's a very
timely great question because I really
thought my life was completely random
and I couldn't understand any of the
decisions I made I never questioned my
decision you look in the mirror and you
say why would you possibly do this
doesn't make any sense and things like
them as a manager you have a right to
Commission the life of the project you
work on so I worked on the Beatles
Anthology record for example I have a
right to collect commissions on that I
always chose not if I'm not working with
the artist I didn't want to take their
money so I chose never to do it which
when you look in the mirror and say what
are you a schmuck
to yourself but if you have a strong
foundation and you can feel that
foundation which is you know I shouldn't
really be making money off base they
going out living their lights their life
it's not my life you go back to and I
always thought all those choices were
just random like maybe I was it was ego
and thinking I was a good guy or I don't
know what the motivation and when I
wrote the book I realized that I'm
actually living my father's life and he
was a man of pure service pure service
to me and my brother and he really gave
up almost everything else in his life
but was joyful because he was serving us
and as I met mentors along with
Roger ver J in particular I saw how he
was the first person I really met who
was very successful and very happy most
of the people I was meeting I would say
99% of the people I met in show business
who were the kingpins were miserable
they were cheating on their wives they
were alcoholics they were they were just
miserable they were just drowning the
pain and I think that those kind of my
dad first and then seeing the methods
made me think you know you're gonna die
with the money enjoy the moments you
here on the planet and if service is a
way to enjoy it and comes naturally to
me
III don't want to fight it by falling
into the traps of all those normal traps
and free stuff I'm I'm good enough at
what I do that I can make a living I've
heard I've heard and I want you to
correct me here but then it took
something like 10 to 12 years for Mike
Myers to get you to agree to do the
documentary maybe you can give me some
some color there but the follow-up to
that is going to be why a book why do a
book yeah I am I've always cautioned my
clients when I started working with them
but if I do my job perfectly I have a
good chance of killing them because I
will make them so famous that they can't
survive so I've always had a very
corrupted view of Fame I realized that's
what I do for a living and I'm good at
it and it can provide great stuff for
people but they have to be prepared that
they're gonna take a fall and hopefully
get up for that fall so the last thing I
really wanted to do was test myself why
would I really want to you know it
didn't make any documentaries are in
financial I didn't view it as being of
service to anybody or anything except my
ego and I didn't want have to deal with
fame I just didn't want to have to flirt
with but I saw too many people I loved
fall victim to it so I said no and
laughed and then I had some near-death
experience and didn't know it luckily
him it was beautiful I woke up in a
hospital burned very drugged out and by
the second day realizing I was very
alone in my life was fairly isolated I
was in a hotel room I just I mean a
hospital I just almost died feeling very
high and I think very starting to feel
really sorry for myself
which is unusual because I'm usually
feeling how lucky I am and right in the
middle of that Mike called how you doing
I said you know I'm really doing visuals
one of the few times in my life I can't
sign the footing I'm like sort of kind
of lost a little bit and he said well
how about doing the movie now we have
now we have like a really dramatic
moment to go to and I think my ego
probably said close fee-only sorry
myself I said yeah yeah maybe that's a
good way to come out of this thing if I
live let's do the movie so I got well
got some good help for my friends and
maybe a month later remembered that I
had told we would do the movie good so I
called them up hey Mike how you doing
great I said you know did we have a
conversation when I was in the hospital
he said do the movie and he said yeah he
said go ahead and do it
I staffed up I got six people okay and I
really assumed that like my cousins in
San Diego would see it but he would
abandon the project er I didn't it was
hard for me to think of it as real and I
knew Mike socially I didn't know
professionally except enjoying his
talent and I didn't realize how driven
he was and he spent the next year his
life seven days a week 24 hours a day on
this thing I I did nothing but I
remember about 11 months into it I got
to New York and I he'd invited me up for
a cup of coffee and say hello and I went
up and I talked to this apartment it was
like walking get the CSI it was pictures
of me right and the movie came out and
at first I was really embarrassed
especially with the name anybody in the
eye when they say oh oh I hear you got a
movie what's it called and I would feel
my eyes go down to the floor I would say
super [ __ ]
look any what at the eye the film
company asked him to come out for a
screening somewhere in the Midwest it
was the first time I had seen it with
the audience it was a Sun Film Festival
and I was really embarrassed I mean like
a truly embarrassment super mention like
oh my god this is this is so egotistical
so now what it's so not what my vision
of myself is but but so I started
questioning my vision of myself but
anyway as the movie's over I walk out
into the lobby and it's very Aryan
couple they almost looked at the top of
a wedding cake right you're standing
there the woman had tears in her eyes
and they just stood in the corner they
waited for everybody to take pictures
you know the things that happen after
screening and I walked over to at the
end they don't so how glad we wanted to
talk to you we just moved here from st.
Thomas and our children are growing up
and there we were empty nesters and we
came back and we realized we have so
much to be blessed for and we just don't
do enough good stuff and watching the
movie made us realize we have to change
that in our lives and we'd love to start
with you and we don't have much but
we're hunters and you said you like to
cook and eat we have a lot of venison in
our freezer can we give you some venison
and I went back to the house got the
venison to turn that my roommate in
college
was their next-door neighbor and Saint
Thomas I had a picture of oh wow
when I saw the effect it had on those
people and then I came back and I
started getting emails and calls we
spoke about Rick Rubin before that's how
we reconnected out of nowhere I hadn't
seen him in 30 years he you got a hold
of me and say can I fly over to Maui and
spend some time with it I saw the movie
and I really could use some time with
him and he came over I hadn't seen him
in 30 years so it affected all I get the
first thing I packaged I got when I got
home was a this beautiful birdcage came
from Africa and it had like 50 white
silk flowers in it and one pink one and
this four-page letter from a girl 19
year old girl
listen I'm not different than the other
flowers but I know if you would let me
out of the cage I could really help my
people you know just these things coming
from every corner so that was the sort
of a side note and I had a friend Roy
Choi a chef who had a book signing in
New York when I was there and he's on
Anthony Bourdain's imprint and I never
met Anthony and I was a huge fan of at
the book signing you walked over to me
and he said hey I want to do your book
hmm maybe this is a moment where I can
try and figure out what motivated me and
maybe if there's anything and what
motivated me that other people can use
maybe some techniques that I never was
aware of but that I can find by looking
backwards and that's really the exercise
they and they agree that if I didn't
want to put out the book I could give
him back the money and we just mend it
so that was the journey for me was to
try and see is it Michael always said
there are these interconnections and I
always thought of my life is random see
are there are they connectors that could
help other people along the way and
hence the book and what impact would you
like the book to have I would like
people to realize how lucky they are I
end the book with maybe the one of the
things that maybe I can add to some
people's lives particularly here in
America which is just where you drop out
of the world you won the game do win it
you want to write you're in America you
have a chance you can get clean water
you get food hopefully you get some love
but not a bomb dropping on your head
every second that alone is something to
meditate on every day how special you
are and how rarefied it is to be born
into something like this and then maybe
the second thing is to try and see the
miracle and everything so that when you
see somebody who you're your initial
reaction its hatred or you see a snail
walking on the ground and your initial
reaction is kick it out of the way to
try and see the miracle and if you see
the miracle in it because everything is
a miracle you're not gonna be only
hurting you you're gonna have a
different attitude towards it to the
person you hate you're gonna feel sorry
for that they don't see the miracle in
themselves and sorrow is a much better
emotion that hatred
selfishly for yourself and in there
there's also practical you know how you
try and make business into compassionate
business how you trying to make it a
win-win not winners and losers and I
talk a lot about how you create history
things like guilt by association taking
a non famous person and putting them
next to famous people the fame starts to
bleed off and we live in a Fame driven
world so for commerce fame support so I
want I want to ask you about regular
practices in your life related to
Buddhism and appreciation in just a
minute but since you brought it up could
you describe what you did for anne-marie
that pertains to your last example of
that fame by association yep yeah it was
a great example of guilt by association
she's a wonderful singer one of the
purest voices I've ever heard she was a
school teacher in Toronto we went on a
TV show for the summer and sang a song
called snow bird which became a
number-one record around the world huge
impact which he was very very very
Canadian white bread and what you wanted
to make it you wanted to be on midnight
special which was a big show there she
wanted to play in Vegas she wanted to do
all the things that stars do but she
wasn't a star she was a girl who had a
hit record that nobody really knew who
sang it so she came to me from
management and one of the first things I
did with her was trying because the song
was so big and so strong I knew that I
can include her and stuff if I had her
with important other people so I booked
her at that time Alice Cooper had a
group called the Hollywood vampires a
drinking group and it was John Lennon
Harry Nielson and Micky Dolenz in the
Monkees big faces at the time
particularly John Lennon who was in his
dark era and was not being seen at all
any luck Yoko for a while he was in
California everyone knew he was there
but nobody was seeing and the press were
anxious to see him so my book there in
California on Thanksgiving which I
thought was a very funny because she was
Canadian I tried to make it always
absurd as I positive
and I got the guys I went to see the
guys and I said I got down on my hands
and knees and they all I used to drive
the more home at night cuz they were all
got too drunk to drive and nobody could
afford cars so I I was a designated
driver so I got down on my hands and
knees and I said guys
I'll Drive you all all the time but you
got to come help me with this girl from
Canada who was so opposite from you that
if you guys would stand next to her I
could help make her famous and I'll
Drive you forever and he came welcome
and we had this great picture of Anne
Marie John Lennon Harry Nielsen Alice
Cooper Micky Dolenz which went out
around the world immediately Midnight
Special called up and have her host the
show and oh by the way think she can get
John to come with her well thrive
Rolling Stone called up for a big
interview she made a bunch of covers
with the picture and for the next year
or so we sort of dangle a little bit
that maybe John or Alice if somebody
would show up and the rest of the sort
of history she got a long-term contract
in Vegas and life went well clear I
didn't know the the contrast aspect of
it that you thought through because when
I looked at the photograph she does pop
out almost like she's superimposed on
top of the photograph she really pops
out I don't know if you ever forgave me
for doing the picture sheesh she thought
she was compromising her career seems to
seems to have worked out pretty well
now you mentioned Roger Roger and a lot
of people associated with music but
you're also very widely credited with
creating the celebrity chef phenomenon
and movement how did you meet Emeril
Lagasse Emeril on a trip to New Orleans
had started to become a little bit of a
foodie because of my association with
mr. Dugray and that in New Orleans there
was a chef named Paul Prudhomme who was
very famous the only really famous chef
and I had a friend of mine who had just
taken over a large record company EMI
and we went down for Jazz Fest and it
was his birthday
so I got a hold of I think it was mr.
Ridgeway or somebody who made
reservations at Paul food homes for the
two nights we were going to be there and
we went the first night now is a not a
good experience so we decided to go
somewhere else the next night we went to
a very touristy but well respected
operation called Commander's Palace oh
yeah very famous but served thousand
meals a day and we had a reservation we
get there a little guy with like half
glasses and wasn't look at us at the
maitre d stand says 45 minute wait take
him to the bar and to get to the bar you
walk through the kitchen unquote this
guy's eye and he came over and gave me a
big hug
I had never been there and said you guys
taken care of and said hooked up I think
was the word seenu's I didn't know as a
matter of fact we got to go then the bar
so he took us to the bar he poured a
champagne came back in five minutes took
us to the a table and proceeded to bring
every course up to the table with the
help and every time he'd leave we'd say
what is this guy think we are and he's
treating me like I'm his best friend for
life but we didn't want to blow our
cover when the meal is over I said some
okay who do you think I am and he said
you know I have no idea mom I didn't
know if he knew about 4j or not which
was always like an underpinning maybe he
knew I was very sure his friend but you
said it's boring here once a month or
once a week I picked someone coming
through the kitchen who I think wants to
go on a ride I took him on a ride and he
took us on a ride then he gave us a note
to go to Tipitina's
to see the Neville Brothers which was
sold out and poured a cold bottle of
cognac at the for paper cups for us to
leave Wow and maybe a couple of years
later maybe a year later a year and a
half two years later I ended up in a
unique situation with 50 or 60 great
chefs who asked me to manage him
Wolfgang Puck Nobu ahold and Paul
Prudhomme and a bunch of a whole big
group of chefs and I remembered Emeril
and how he treated me and I said you
know I'll do it but as one guy in New
Orleans I want to bring him Emeril
Lagasse and they had all heard him I
didn't realize at the time he had just
opened his own restaurant that's why
they
and I called Commander's Palace to tell
him what I was doing and see if he
wanted to join and they said he opened
his own restaurant his emeralds and our
journey began Wow
I mean we could go into so many
different rabbit holes with all these
stories but I'd love to talk about some
of your practices current practices we
were talking about recognizing the
miracles and by extension appreciation
what practices do you have in your life
to help cultivate that and maintain that
perspective I'm not a practicing
Buddhist and I don't really practice any
hard and fast discipline what I try and
do in my life is Joseph Campbell always
talked about going into a quiet room -
20 minutes and doing what makes you
happy
hmm and what I try and do is schedule I
know things that make me happy I know
being in a jacuzzi makes me happy I
don't know why but I get it a jacuzzi I
sort of leave my body I space travel I
deal with issues that I don't deal with
when I'm in my body or you know
perceived to me to be in it and that's
15 or 20 minutes I usually say it's like
a tuning fork I do that by cooking for
me gives me that same headspace so when
I get to a point where I'm starting to
get confused I'll go to the kitchen and
cook for a half-hour and that sort of
brings me back to a place of
thankfulness
consciousness
focus just brings you back to where I
want to be and I think for me those are
the two that I really use as my
foundation when I'm truly lost
I go to Lewiston when I try and but but
I think you know I I think if you're
lucky in life you find you find those
things that which would get you back to
what's important because if there's so
much fool's gold
there's so much noise but to really stay
focused on what's important and what
makes you happy and what does
compassionate is difficult and I think
needs constant retuning what what if you
noticed I mean you mentioned you
mentioned the dangers of Fame and how a
lot of these celebrities just become
moths who are consumed by the the flame
so to speak what separates the people
who get killed by fans the people who do
not you know one thing I always say Fame
and I realize that I I need to put a
qualifier on which i didn't do in the
movie or really in the book I need to
qualify it by saying that the fame that
I've dealt with for most of my life was
famed attained by people who were in
front of large audiences in real time so
the 90% of my artists which he's Fame
had a live people applauding in mass
amounts as opposed to film stars as
opposed to authors as opposed to people
who got Fame in other ways so mine is
fairly slanted and I think so for me my
until I really wrote the book it started
to think about these things might my
saying those words was because the
people in front of me would normally
trying to be headliners in stadiums and
for that subgroup of people I think it
rejection is so gigantic to get to a
place of success that there's normally
something driving that some hole
somewhere in their life something that
they need filled maybe it's love from
other people maybe
so I don't know in each person it's
different maybe they they don't have a
personality so that's their personality
but when you get to fulfilling a thirty
thousand seat home for the most part
whatever that hole was doesn't get
filmed and that's when the real problems
begin and that's what you see an artist
when they're selling 300 and 400 C balls
they're they're fine they may have a
drunk with you when they're in lining
stadiums now they go to rehab it's part
of the tour
let's see you'll 265 days then we'll go
to rehab so I think my view of it is
very slanted but I think there's you
know so many common things about I was
talking to my first glint of fame was
they were playing the movie at the
Tribeca Film Festival and Michael
Douglas was doing a talk with me and I
was walking to it and walking for me is
one of the things like the jacuzzi or
this cooking when I'm walking I don't
put headphones and I sort of space
travel and deal with issues you know
I'll deal with the topic that's been on
my brain and I love that that's what I
love about walking I walk five miles a
day here I walk in New York a lot and
it's quiet time because I'm not famous
so nobody stops me nobody cares so I'm
taking my walking very nice lady said
she worked at CNN they had just screened
the movie did I have a few minutes to
talk to her I stopped her a minute
she explained the key they've been
trying to get into management and
production she had had problems as a
child at home she wanted me to talk to
her about how I overcame those
insecurities of youngness to become Who
I am and my instinct would be to be
thankful to be able to help him that
those are the moments you want in life
where you can you know help somebody who
needs help and but I couldn't I had to
get to get at the theater and as I was
walking nationally I explained to him
really sorry I gave my email as I was
walking I started thinking about someone
like Michael
whoo I've walked with a million times he
gets stopped by every single person once
a picture wants to tell him a story
about how he met his father once it's
all great stuff but to completely lose
your own path in life you're now on
someone else's path I'm sure it happens
to you many times and it's weird
that's a weird thing to cope with yeah
it's it's really I don't know if you've
if you experienced this that time but
it's it's really sad and frustrating
also because the person who you told you
had to leave to go to this meeting may
or may not have even believed you right
correct no I realize no you you know I
like to think of myself as a Johnny
Appleseed of joy and you so anyway my
question to Michael when I got there was
he sneezed I said before you asked me a
question I gotta ask you a question I
said I just the last 30 minutes of my
walk I got stopped by this girl and for
the last 30 minutes of my walk all I
thought about was how horrible it is
that I couldn't give her what she needed
it was so simple and was she angry was
she's not angry
which he ever contact me Walker and
Michael that what goes through your said
I'm the guy who's put up his arm for 30
years to keep people from him what goes
through your brain when there's a guy in
a wheelchair and we walk by him and you
know he wants to stop you for a second
it's important to him and you were just
walking behind and you've been doing
this your whole life
what is that effect and he said you know
it's horrible but you know what you get
numb to it he said I hate to admit it I
hate that it happens to me but you
realize it you only have 24 hours in a
day to get through life and you have to
make some choices and it's horrible
because it takes an age of who I'd like
to think I am so those kind of things
build up you know that's just one little
part of Fame where if you're a conscious
good person all of a sudden you start
hating yourself what you have to do all
the time and I don't know if this is
it's maybe completely unrelated but I
heard from a mutual friend that someone
came to your house recently wanted to
share a record but that you didn't have
any type of music system and
and had a music system for 20-plus years
is that is that true and if so why is
that Rick Rubin okay I have no idea why
except that I I almost feel cheated if I
don't hear the ocean the rhythm is this
ocean like I'm hearing it now is just so
beautiful and so the rhythm of life and
I feel so blessed to be on and hear that
I almost it almost felt like an
intrusion so many times mm-hmm
so Rick Rubin came and I had I think I
mentioned it before we had a nice lunch
and we thought and then he wanted to
play me something nice about your hopes
I listened to my car I don't really have
stuff to listen here so he outfitted my
house with Sonos but today I'm really
happy I have because I use it a lot and
I do realize that music was sort of
missing in my life and it really is
heightened my my life here what type of
music do you currently listen to the
most I would say 90% of time I listen to
Teddy Pendergrass radio and Pandora
no kidding I'll have to do that I use I
listen to Pandora on my sonís every day
while I'm writing so I'll see see how
Teddy treats me it really makes you feel
good
it just makes me feel good like makes me
smile every time his voice does not post
I love his music I'm going to ask just a
couple of short questions and the
answers don't need to be short but these
are some of the questions that I love
asking everybody that I have on the show
and you can certainly punt if one
doesn't provoke anything in you but what
book or books you know besides your own
have you gifted most to other people
Joseph Campbell many many years ago a
couple of the Dali Lama books most
recently Norman Lear's book the is it a
biography of Norman Lear sabaki it is
just the most brilliant thing ever in
that grid on Keith Richards book I gave
away a bunch of those guys thought it
was his voice was so pure yeah I've
heard tremendous things about that as
well
and renting it myself to a lot of
artists friends of mine saying you're
ever gonna write a book you want your
voice to sound to be as clear as his
voice was it was him and questlove's
cookbook question that's right what is
it what is it all innovative cooking
innovative cooking he is the nicest guy
week oh is that right he was another one
who reached out saw the documentary and
said I really would love to speak to you
for a while a little dinner party for me
in LA and then he came out here for a
week which was really nice he's a he's
an extremely nice guy I met him years
ago and believe it or not that's at one
point at least and he's spoken about
this lost I think it was 50 to 70 pounds
following the slow carb diet my second
book no kidding yeah yeah he's such a
sweetheart of a guy you know he's a real
artist I I don't meet that many pure
artists anymore because I'm not living
in that world mm-hmm but everything he
touches I went to see he was doing a DJ
thing I had never been to a DJ show and
he didn't hear and it was brilliant but
is the cookbook is brilliant it's
completely different than anything
you've ever read great cover - yeah
great cover if you could have a gigantic
billboard anywhere what would it say
today if I had a gigantic billboard I
would would be completely different -
probably any other time in life and I
don't want to talk to politics but I
think everyone has an obligation to try
and highlight how filthy this has all
become about disastrous and how long so
I think although I normally would say I
would use it for something completely
different like climate change or right
now I just really scared to see the
direction of our country
a country that I love that's given
everybody such great opportunity do you
have a quote or any quotes that you live
your life by or think of often yeah
really I think my professional capacity
get the money I definitely have to force
myself to think of that but not really
I'm very lucky I'm really thankful I
look very simple life at its core so now
I don't really there's no real every
second of my life is just I'm really
blessed I'm lucky who are I'm just
arbitrarily pulling out a number here
but three people or sources that you've
learned a lot from or followed closely
in the last year or so will come back to
Ellen what is the best or most
worthwhile investment you've made and by
investment it could be money time energy
for instance there's a woman named
Amelia Boone she's one of the world's
top endurance athletes who was on this
podcast and for her it was paying her
first $450 which was a financial stretch
at the time to enter a competition
called world's toughest mutter which he
ended up winning and it created this
whole path for her in life that she
never would have anticipated does any
particular investment of money time or
energy my investment of money time and
energy was for the poor children I
raised to see the the effect it can have
on a human's life and then I could be
hopeful on it and all of our our Oliver
alder children are adopted yeah I never
quite it you know I never adopted him it
was there all their family from Newark
three sisters and a brother and in the
days when I when their mother died it
was a huge safety net for children
without parents the government provided
huge benefits and although we didn't
partake of any of the benefits I never
really I'm not an accumulator mm-hmm so
I could have been broken anytime I lived
by making money but I wasn't an
accumulator and I didn't want the
responsibility on my head of
once I adopted him they lost the entire
safety net oh I see just the change in
legal status your legal status changed
everything the consequence is to be with
it they couldn't be a tax deduction
I see now by accumulator does that mean
that you historically or even still
currently don't save I say but I'm not a
I'm not a billionaire right most most
people are at a point now in my life
where I can maintain my lifestyle mm-hmm
like I feel confident for the rest of my
life I can maintain my lifestyle I'm
probably more than my lifestyle but in
1970 19 whatever year was that I thought
1992 I think we got together when I was
26 years ago whatever that is I didn't
know if I I didn't know that I would be
able to keep my lifestyle was only
dependent on being successful right and
I just didn't want that on my head it
was easier for me to pay the taxes on
the money and that was really the only
dividing line mm-hmm so what what advice
would you give to it I have at least
three friends who have brand-new infants
right now or are going to have their
first kids in the next several months
what advice would you give to them as
first-time parents spend time with them
provide them with all the tools they
need as a little TV as possible and lots
of love just love and compassion and see
that if they see the miracle in that kid
every time they look at it they will
never get annoyed at them crying or
screaming they're pissing on the floor
it'll all become a miracle I'm beautiful
and that's what it should be
I remembered yeah I mean it's it seems
like something that might be easy for
people to gloss over with the the
spending of time but it's it's something
that was emphasized to me also by Seth
Godin who's an author among other things
and he said you know you're in effect
I'm paraphrasing here but he said to me
that you
your kids are getting homeschooled from
3 p.m. to say 10:00 p.m. no matter what
and it's up to you to choose whether
it's by watching TV they're getting
homeschooled or by interacting with them
and you know he has conversations with
them over dinner
a lot of the time that's his one of his
rituals because it offers sort of a very
informal semi distracted environment in
which they can tell him the truth
without having a serious feel to it if
that makes any sense I think it's you
know I think the thing to remember is
that they they only have one path and
it's there it's so if you if you make a
path for them that's compassionate and
reasonable it makes sense
that's the only path they know if you
give them a path of neglecting of
letting TVs teach him everything they're
gonna live in an alienated world so I
promised I would so I'm gonna come back
to but we can skip this one if need be
the people or sources you've learned
from learned a lot from and you know
what you mentioned mentors earlier this
could be way back in the day it doesn't
have to be recent I think some of the
most significant people in my life I'm
pretty sure Roger Berger Jay who was a
great French chef considered maybe the
Godfather of Alda Jetson and for people
who want to look him up how do you spell
his last name BER GE he through his
kitchen came people like Danielle blue
David boule Alain Ducasse you bear
Keller some of the great chefs of our
time I came through this kitchen and and
what he taught me is you can be
successful and happy and you do it
through service and that's a hard
concept sometimes to get in your brain
but when you when I got to spend time
and I could see in some ways how selfish
it was because he became so happy making
someone else happy and then I had the
unbelievable luck in honor of meeting
His Holiness is Ollie longer cooking for
him on a number of occasions and the
same thing it's service makes him so
joyful he giggles every second
and he lives his life of service for me
those were probably my two greatest
mentors and then someone like Michael
Douglas has always been an amazing
inspiration to me you know the work he
does quietly for the UN for Israel for
anybody who needs him things that he
feels are important he's been on an
anti-nuclear kick for as long as I know
in probably 35 years before anybody was
talking about he's been an ambassador
for the UN he never says no to helping
people and he has a fun lives his life
creative he's productive doesn't take
security with him lives his life and and
as a service and he I'm doing a benefit
in New York in September for Schaeffler
Jay with the CIA and 12 great shots and
Michael's coming and talking just
because I asked him to and there was a
time when I was trying to make the
chef's famous I wanted guilt by
association to the chef's so I asked him
if he would host dinners with all the
famous people in LA who would come if
you invite him with my chefs with mr.
Baer Jay and we had these dinners where
Michael would present for Jay in the
room would be Stallone Nicholson Danny
DeVito Anthony Quinn you know and guilt
by association work as you could tell
they are celebrity chefs now so I think
he's have been a big inspiration I've
been very lucky to have a lot of people
Indy I mean the eve past that on also I
mean if you just look at the culinary
world is one example I mean you and for
people who want to check it out I mean
you give a great I think it was a
commencement speech at the CIA which I
should probably explain for people is
not the Central Intelligence Agency yeah
The Culinary Institute of America and
you you mentioned that you know before
the celebrity chef phenomenon in a way
sort of paved the highway I think as you
put it yes the people at the top of
their game I mean these are the the a
rods or the Derek Jeter's of their
sports
to speak in the cooking in the world of
chefs we're making like a hundred grand
a year and now you can come out of
culinary school and some people will get
entry level or I should say first jobs
that are a hundred thousand dollars so
it's it's really opened up a world of
opportunity for those people as well and
a world of caution as I said in the CIA
speech that they if their only focus is
making meals that people pay $100 a
piece for they're in for a big crash
them and the culinary arts yeah I have
to snap this thought feeding and I said
in you know I told the killers that
you're gonna graduate you're gonna get a
job printer in a quarter you're gonna be
in a restaurant that's 400 all good
meals and you're gonna walk outside the
restaurant look to the left and look to
the right and there's gonna be homeless
hungry people and if you think your only
job is feeding those Niners you working
for a really rough life yeah definitely
and I want to give credit to somebody
you mentioned earlier in fact Roy Choi
so he and a friend of mine named Steve
Jiang who's involved and also Daniel
Patterson who has in a quite a few
restaurants one of which alta SF I'm
involved with in San Francisco great
guys and they have started believe there
are at least two locations now a
low-cost healthy food local L okay L
okay Oh L and I went to their first
location opening in Los Angeles and so
he's doing really good work I think in
trying to give it back he's he's the
real deal
is there there's a fellow from England
Jamie Oliver who really in my opinion
was the first really conscious chef I
added a celebrity chef movement I think
they're all I don't mean to say that any
of the other ones aren't conscious he
was a fellow who understood that it was
important for him to use his fame did
not only do hundred-dollar meals and a
Roy Choi's
has picked up the gauntlet beards I I
got very lucky to know him well and he
is the real deal boy he really gets it I
mean he wants to make money he wants to
send his kids to college he wants to do
all the things that we all want to do
for our families
sure he wants to be famous like
everybody else but he completely
understands and we all have to travel
together this is longer one person
journey yeah definitely did a did a hell
of a job training jon favreau for chef
as well so I just add just a couple of
last questions and hearing the sound of
the waves is making me want to get
outside go for a long walk
oh yeah I can definitely hear it's
making me want to chase daylight to go
for a hike with my dog there is that
rhythm this exists all over the planet
whether it's the breeze coming through
the trees or the sound of the waves or
you know the snow the ice melting or
those sounds that just you sort of know
your home it's it's met it's meditative
very meditative so one question I have
to ask is for for all the people out
there who may one day end up cooking for
the Dalai Lama
should you have yak milk tea on the menu
of maybe you could provide some if you
have any experience I was really
fortunate they accepted he was coming to
Hawaii and they accepted my offer to
cook them and again I'm not a practicing
Buddhist and I didn't know a lot about
his holiness and I did some research and
I assumed he was vegetarian I couldn't
get anybody to bettan people are so
beautiful and so gentle when you ask
them what should I make for as Onis they
would never it's so aggressive for them
to tell you what to make oh he would
love anything you make they're
completely of service so I couldn't
really find out but I in the research it
said that the only real staple in Tibet
is yak yak is a cross I think between
like a goat and account and they live
high in the mountains there's no
vegetables really there that so
everything's made from yak yak
you yak milk yak butter yak cheese and
the most popular thing is yak tea so I
have a friend who does tours of Tibet
wonderful guy named Kenny Malek and I
asked her if he could get me some yak
butter and make yak tea so that I could
have yak tea for His Holiness for his
first breakfast thinking I was oh my god
how cool was this I'm so cool that I get
the yak butter and it's the smelliest
thing you've ever so is in a jar I've
still smelled up my whole house it was
it's so smelly but I had it and I get
there but for the only the only
requirement for cooking to him they
asked me no questions and they didn't
necessarily said was you can't have
expectations if you have an expectation
that you're gonna meet his holiness then
you shouldn't cook for him so we got I
went to my crew we got all those
expectations out of our brain you have
to assume you're not gonna meet him
we're gonna cook the meal someone's
gonna deliver it to him you're doing
this for service not for a photo-op and
the first morning they asked me to bring
him his meal now I'm completely shocked
because I assume I'm not even meeting
him and it's 5 o'clock in the morning
and one of the things on the tray is the
yak tea so I put it they have you cover
your mouth defeat his holiness I covered
my mouth and I go up the steps into his
room and I walk in and he's in his robe
with top down his chest was bare and
he's brushing his teeth looking in the
mirror and gets a big smile hello big
smile
hello your holiness I'm so nervous I
could hardly I can hardly speak I tend
to get nervous in front of power figures
particularly at that point in my life
now I'm sort of adjusted but that was
almost overwhelming I just didn't want
to faint and take some wood fortuity
goes oh yeah tea and I said like I got
so proud like oh my gosh have you pulled
this off it's so amazing was worth all
the effort all the smell you are the
coolest guy in the world
and I hear it's a has I'm telling myself
this is second lie this oh that's why I
leave to bed it smells so bad
man well we could we could go on for
days and I don't want to keep you for
days
but IIIi want people to hear your
stories and to learn from you what is
the title of the book where can people
find it what would you suggest people do
who want to learn more well the
backstage pass look up the title and I
can I can certainly link to and also in
the show notes for people here just want
the convenience they it's a is the name
they called me supermen a backstage pass
in the amazing world of film food and
RocketBallz Superman it's um it's could
be awarded through Amazon or any of
those services it's published by a young
Anthony Bourdain through Eko
I'm really proud to have Anthony is the
publisher and I hope everybody enjoys it
and for those people listening I will of
course link to everything in the show
notes at 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash podcast and Shep any last words
any requests of the audience for them to
take with them and consider or act on
anything else you'd like to to say
before we before we wrap up this is so
out of my wheelhouse but the only I
really have to say is please go vote mmm
we need everybody to close their
conscience or think about their children
and not what kind of world they want to
live
mm-hmm then make a choice but but this
is an in critical time we need to vote
absolutely hear hear well Shep I hope we
do get to meet in person sometime and
there's so much here this has been a
blast I do show I listen to it well III
think you're doing import
work and we didn't even have a chance to
skim the surface really of a lot of what
you're doing right now but I will add I
will do another show maybe I can have
one of those papayas and I thank you so
much for the time I really really
appreciate it thank you have a great day
definitely and everyone listening as
always thank you so much for joining us
and until next time pay attention
experiment often be nice and pay
attention to the miracles hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday the vet provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by audible
which I've used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing you will thank me
the graveyard book the second is
vagabonding by Rolf pots which had a
huge impact on my life and formed the
basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so
all you need to do to get your free
30-day trial is go to audible.com
forward slash tim TI m and you can
choose one of those two books or you can
choose from more great options than you
can possibly imagine so that could be a
book that could be a magazine that can
be a newspaper could be a class it's
that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible.com forward
slash Tim and grab a book enjoy this
episode is brought to you by me undies
if I'm not going commando I'm in the
envyus I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell two times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the cob bottom method sounds very fancy
of course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies com forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing their ridiculous the sublime
everything in-between including my
favorite which is called out and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention their
lounge pants this is a new thing and
I've been wearing their lounge pants
when I record podcasts I've been wearing
them out and about when I'm walking the
dog meeting people for coffee and they
are extremely comfortable they're made
from the same material as the underwear
but some of them like the blue ones I
have have pockets so you can walk about
without seeming like you're off of your
meds and completely crazy so that is
awesome
and if you're not happy with the first
pair you try on I assume that refers to
the underwear they'll refund you
completely and you can keep the prairie
try it on for free but if you're that
kind of person you should be ashamed
because that's disgusting
me Andy's Campos wash Tim check it out
you